[Music]
so when it's all said and done prepare
to have
20 to 30 beautiful women you get to
select from
like a dollar menu at mcdonald's
[Music]
i'm not so sure you want to be taking
this guy's advice you know
the dollar menu i mean comes in clutch
in a pinch but uh
i don't i don't know that that's the
type of
i don't know like a dollar menu at
mcdonald's
let me tell you a little about who the
hell i am oh boy
here we go again guys if you don't know
who the hell this is this is
adrien g we talked about him in our last
video but he's back
and better than ever last time he was
telling us how to get rich before i show
you how to make six figures a year by
working just
one day a week from your laptop this
time he's telling you
how to get laid i'm a world renowned
dating group this man
is apparently an expert in the art of
pickup
he's an artist they call themselves
pickup artists
in this community they charge insecure
men a lot of money
to teach them how to be more confident
with the ladies
my name is adrian grushka but since
we're soon share a brotherhood you can
just call me adrian g
or aj for sure that's right you're about
to join the simp
brotherhood the knights of the single
table the fellowship
of the incel but this guy in particular
it's shady he's giving off some serious
um
vibes some serious yes means no vibes
if you catch my drift i've been teaching
guys how to bag the world's sexiest
women like groceries
for the past four years and there's
warning flag number one women like
groceries
bag and women like groceries adrian
that's a little creepy my man
it's weirder than calling your women
like they're from a mcdonald's dollar
menu
very strange i got online and feverishly
began studying
all the greatest pickup artists such as
mystery
neil strauss jt tran and plenty others
until i couldn't stuff my brain anymore
i was now
programmed to learn and master the art
of dropping panties without me even
asking
i mean are you trying to me too yourself
right now they're gonna look back on
this like we should have known without
me
the things he was saying here we should
have known all along
it's a little suspicious very suspicious
but if you can believe it it gets even
worse imagine
[Music]
all the work that goes into
creating a new cure for a disease no
all the field tests and clinical trials
no
don't do it don't compare yourself to a
scientist
and that is the level i was doing this
maniacal research on
ah there there he goes he's trying to
give himself the nobel prize
pick up right now relax you're a
narcissistic 20 year old
you're not einstein but believe it or
not it gets
even worse and just kept on learning
interacting
and testing out thousands of methods on
my new prey
[Music]
hello 911 imagine calling yourself the
master of women
and then calling them prey and saying
you're packing them like groceries dude
this guy's never done anything but play
some kind of waifu simulator this guy
has no experience with real women
actually i take that back i've been
looking into it
fast forward future steven here actually
he does have
some experience with women he has
experience hiring actors
for his pranks in fact because he ran a
social experiment channel he's one of
these guys
but he actually got called out for some
of his pranks pranks right
uh for for them being absolutely fake
whole video is a lie
because everyone in it's an actor yeah
but you haven't revealed that to
anyone yeah right is that right i mean
no that's not right yeah
my man is caught in the act and he goes
yeah that's right wait
wait no uh wait uh what was the question
this is the girl at glenelg that tells
you this is one of the other girls
they're all actors they all follow your
profile your acting profile
on a star now that's just creepy dude i
think we're done
we need those kind of reporters in
america where are those reporters that's
no seriously that's just creepy
why do you do that turns out all that
methodical research he was doing
was looking for actors he's admitted
this clip too
was staged
[Music]
as were others here's an ad looking for
girls to be in another video with offers
of a cash payment
this is the guy we're dealing with guys
this is the pickup master
anyways guys let's get back into the
into the video to be honest
in this economy i had originally planned
to give this system away
for absolutely free he's gonna try to
justify it boys
tell me if you think his justification
makes any sense okay
he he wants to give it to you for free
that is until i realized such a move
would turn out to be
counterproductive and ruin the mission
of what i actually set out to do
you see if this info was given away
it would saturate the babe market and
your stock would crash
my man's out here on some nasdaq he's
he's a standards and poor's man
i call it the potential babe bubble and
that
see yes he's worried about the
great 2008 babe crash again he doesn't
want to be responsible for that so he's
doing the only thing he knows how
and charging outrageous sums of money
for obvious information
and that is why i made the decision i
must charge for this program
for your protection don't you just feel
his sincerity there i must charge for
this program
i'll be honest this pickup artistry
stuff is
pretty freaking weird women pick up on
this kind of stuff
they can tell when you're thinking to
yourself oh look at what my new prey is
doing you're going to smell it on you
from a mile away
not going to go well so anyway i just
wanted to share that with you guys
have a little laugh with me about the
insanity
of adrien g anyway that's it for now
thanks for watching
and don't forget to smash like and
subscribe
thank you burn through your plastic
stacks
[Music]
a mouth full of money
[Music]
comes along